et l'info dans nos régions qui nous
amène du côté du havre ce matin le havre
où se déroule pendant deux jours le
havre forum et pour en parler nous
retrouvons sur place edouard philippe
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin ancien premier ministre et
maire du havre et je le disais dans
quelques instants vous allez donc ouvrir
inauguré ce havre forum qui se tient
pendant deux jours dans votre vie le
thème choisi cette année c'est
l'économie maritime d'abord en quoi
consiste ce havre forum qu'est ce qui va
se passer pendant deux jours
ça fait dix ans qu avant la fin du mois
de septembre on organise pendant deux
jours un forum dont l'objectif est de
discuter d'échanger sur des questions
relatives à ce qu'on appelle ici
l'économie positive c'est à dire au fond
la façon dont on réfléchit au long terme
dans l'activité de produire pas
simplement pour produire mais ses
implications sur l'environnement ces
implications sur la société ont choisi
chaque année un thème est cette année
c'est le thème de l'économie bleus le
thème de l'eau le thème de la planète
bleue qui est au centre de nos
discussions avec des chefs d'entreprise
avec des responsables associatifs avec
des universitaires avec des responsables
politiques avec tous ceux qui ont envie
au fond d'échanger des idées voyez le
havre c'est un lieu où on échange des
marchandises parce que c'est un grand
port et puis c'est aussi un lieu où on
échange les idées parce que réfléchir
voir loin c'est absolument essentiel
dans le monde dans lequel nous vivons
quel est le poids aujourd'hui de
l'économie maritime pour la ville du
havre
pour le fck absolument considérable et
ici je peux me permettre c'est important
pour le voir mais c'est surtout
important pour le pays l'économie bleus
au havre la zone industrialo portuaire
c'est plus de 30000 emplois c'est 3
millions de containers qui chacun et pas
ce soit qu'ils arrivent souhaite qu'ils
partent du port du havre c'est donc un
élément essentiel une porte d'entrée de
la france et même du continent européen
pour le monde et c'est aussi le port
d'exportation d'un très grand nombre de
productions songez par exemple que le
havre est le plus grand port viticoles
du monde
c'est par le havre que transitent chaque
année le champagne le cognac le vin tous
les alcools qui ensuite font une partie
de la richesse française en contribuant
au commerce extérieur emmanuel macron et
est à nice il ya quelques jours aux
assises de l'économie de la mer et le
chef de l'état il a appelé à aller plus
vite pour refaire de la france une
grande puissance maritime quel rôle vous
pouvez jouer vous dans cette stratégie
d'abord il a parfaitement raison
président de la république en
s'engageant au service de l'économie
maritime de ce défi maritime et il
défend les intérêts stratégiques de la
france et je le soutiens totalement sur
ce point aussi je le dis parce que
aujourd'hui le commerce maritime c'est
80 % c'est même un peu plus 80% du
commerce physique de marchandises c'est
à dire que tout ce qui fait le commerce
aujourd'hui passe par la mer passe par
des porcs et donc avoir des places
portuaires importante avoir des flottes
maritimes importante c'est être
compétitif dans le monde c'est pouvoir
défendre sa souveraineté c'est pouvoir
se placer sur les grandes routes
commerciales et donc ses pouvoirs par
exemple permettre de la réimplantation
industriel c'est donc des enjeux qui
sont considérables crois que le
président de la république les a
parfaitement saisi en indiquant qu'il
voulait développer la politique
portuaire en indiquant qu'il voulait
augmenter le nombre de français qui sont
formés pour être marin dans la marine
marchande tous ces sujets là sont
essentiels ils sont souvent un peu
méconnu je dois dire alors évidemment au
havre le vivent on le vit parfois avec
un peu de frustration parce que on sait
combien la mer est importante ils sont
parfois un peu méconnu des politiques
publiques et le fait que le président de
la république à nice ce soit très
directement et très personnellement
impliqué dans la défense de l'économie
maritime par une excellente nouvelle
trop méconnu passé traités par les
politiques menées comment vous
l'expliquez ça a été un peu délaissé ce
sujet
il ya des explications qui sont très
diverses les historiens vous dirais que
avec fernand braudel
la france c'est rêver à partir d'un
certain moment comme une puissance
continentale beaucoup plus que comme une
puissance océanique on pourrait dire
aussi que dans les quarante ou cinquante
dernières années notre pays a consacré
une bonne partie de son intelligence de
ses moyens de ses capacités
d'investissement à des projets qui
n'étaient pas maritimes et portuaires et
et après tout c'était des choix publics
et il était parfaitement légitime mais
ce qui est vrai c'est que dans cette
compétition maritime et portuaire la
france est menacée d'une certaine façon
ou en tout cas elle n'est pas aussi
puissante que sa géographie que son
histoire maritime aussi lui permettrait
d'être donc il ya un enjeu considérable
sur la flotte sur la marine marchande
sur la marine évidemment de combat sur
wii sur la marine sur les places
portuaires
sur leur développement
industriel sur leur capacité à
constituer je pense notamment à
marseille au havre et à dunkerque des
portes d'entrée continental il faut il
faut véritablement comprends ça plus les
flux de marchandises passent par chez
nous plus nous avons des chances de
localiser de la production industrielle
près de chez nous et ça c'est un enjeu
de politique économique c'est pas un
enjeu de politique maritime c'est un
enjeu de politique économique aidant
philippe vous nous parliez de
l'importance de la puissance du port du
havre le port de cherbourg lille a vu
son trafic triplé avec le break c'est
est ce que le havre a aussi tiré profit
de rex it
on est un peu moins touchés ici par les
effets directs du breakbeat d'abord
parce que l'essentiel de notre trafic
ont bien évidemment du transmanche et on
a été affecté à la fois par le brr exit
et par la crise sanitaire
mais l'essentiel du trafic au havre est
un trafic de marchandises et un trafic
qui vient de loin donc on n'a pas la
même exposition si j'ose dire aux effets
du bric site que ça peut être le cas à
cherbourg ou plus plus au nord à calais
ce qui est certain c'est que le brésil
nous a imposé de réorganiser nos flux
nos éléments de sécurité les éléments
liés à la douane et que le travail a été
bien fait par les services de l'état qui
très tôt se sont mobilisés pour faire en
sorte que pour l'usagé ce soit le plus
transparent possible
ce qui est certain aussi c'est que nous
vivons encore avec des incertitudes sur
la mise en oeuvre pratique et durable
des éléments liés au parasite je pense
notamment aux langridge comme on
l'appelle et aux relations entre
l'irlande et le royaume uni et puis la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on est encore
très affecté par les restrictions
sanitaires alors elle se lève
progressivement au royaume uni elle
s'allège j'ai compris qu'il y avait des
décisions d'allègement qui allait
intervenir en france tant mieux mais on
n'a pas encore revu au havre l'intensité
du trafic notamment du trafic passagers
entre le royaume uni la france et leur
fils dit vous qu'être maire du havre on
imagine que vous suivez avec une grande
attention tout ce qui concerne la
question de territoire territoire c'est
un mot qui est très à la mode en ce
moment où xavier bertrand il va jusqu'à
faire campagne pour une république des
territoires est ce que pour vous
aujourd'hui il faut aller plus loin en
matière de décentralisation
jeu j'entends
l'appétence général je me réjouis
d'ailleurs pour les capacités des
collectivités territoriales a essayé de
participer à la résolution des problèmes
du pays et ça me paraît une bonne idée
moi je crois va alors on a un effort à
faire collectivement c'est pas
d'ailleurs quelque chose de cliver
politiques pensent que je suis en train
de dire on a me semble-t-il un effort à
faire pour réfléchir à l'organisation
territoriale
et beaucoup d'acteurs ils sont même un
peu foisonnant tout ça me paraît pouvoir
être repensé je le crois alors il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas d'urgence enfin ce
serait bien qu'on se mette autour d'une
table sans arrière pensée
reconnaissez avec moi que la diversité
et le foisonnement des structures
territoriales
n'est pas toujours n'est pas toujours un
élément de fluidité bon alors on peut
ensuite réfléchir à des compétences
nouvelles pour les collectivités
territoriales pourquoi pas franchement
pourquoi pas mais je pense qu'il faut
que plus fondamentalement que cela notre
pays collectivement nous réfléchissions
à l'organisation que nous voulons dont
nous voulons nous doter des
collectivités territoriales de l'état de
la fiscalité fiscalité locale ses
qualités de l'état jeu je me permet
d'indiquer qu'à mon sens il est
préférable de vouloir enfin il est
préférable de voir loin de réfléchir au
système que nous voulons construire
plutôt que de discuter de façon très
saccadée sur telle ou telle mesure parce
que j'aimerais c'est que le débat public
peut-être le débat électoral de
l'élection présidentielle puisse nous
permettre de faire le tri entre les
différentes options est de savoir quelle
république nous voulons construire
quel état nous voulons construire il ya
évidemment un besoin de modernisation il
ya évidemment un besoin de fluidité
d'agilité les collectivités
territoriales peuvent considérablement
aidé c'est certain mais encore une fois
la réflexion elle doit être globale et
surtout surtout ne pas se transformer en
un débat
que je crois stérile entre les
collectivités territoriales d'un côté
dont on supposerait la cohérence et
l'état de l'autre dont on supposera
l'incapacité à agir je crois que comme
ça on ne règlera rien et donc vivre le
débat public vive la réflexion et vive
la capacité à voir loin
les maires sont au centre du jeu en ce
moment ils sont très courtisés 1 par de
nombreuses personnalités est ce que
cette manière de les mettre au centre du
jeu ça vous agace ça vous flatte
aujourd'hui pour peser faut être mère
au coûteux jeu moi j'ai tendance à
penser que les maires ils sont depuis
longtemps au centre du jeu les gens qui
disent aujourd'hui les maires sont au
centre du jeu ça fera que ça fait
longtemps qu'ils n'ont pas compris
comment ça se passe et localement c'est
vrai que les mères chez eux ils ont une
place qui est à la fois très
particulière et assez prééminente bon
voilà ça fait pas d'eux des supers élu
par rapport aux autres on a le droit de
rester humble et de regarder la façon
dont les choses fonctionnent en vain
mais de toute façon ils sont par la
reconnaissance de leurs concitoyens par
le caractère très large des compétences
qu'ils exercent dans leur commune ils
sont évidemment d'une certaine façon au
centre du jeu alors je comprends les
échéances électorales c'est débile savez
ils sont au centre du jeu politique
national quand vous voyez à une dalle go
qu'ils ont une équipe de crise
toujours été au centre du jeu
est ce que vous vous allez j'en sais
vous allez lancer sur se dit aujourd'hui
c'est tant mieux vous allez lancer à et
d'infini bout de votre formation
politique dans quelques jours ce sera le
9 octobre elle sera aussi centré autour
des mers cette formation politique
je crois que ras un certain nombre de
maires qui me rejoindront je l'espère
d'ailleurs parce que ce sont souvent des
amis et puis je crois qu'ils se ils se
reconnaissent dans la façon dont j'ai
envie de participer au débat public
c'est à dire plutôt en essayant de voir
loin plus tôt
nuance est plutôt en reconnaissant la
complexité des sujets qu en disant que
tout ça est très facile quitte à
s'exposer une fois qu'on est au pouvoir
à des déconvenues donc oui j'espère
qu'il aura des mères mais il n'y aura
pas que des maires il y aura tous les
françaises et les français qui se
reconnaissent dans une une façon de
faire de la politique et dans un dans
des valeurs que j'exposerai
ou
à quelle échéance
le le débat public je les ai toujours
dit je le pense très sincèrement
gagnerait à réfléchir à ce que nous
voulons faire de la france un des
échéances qui ne sont pas
immédiates actualité ou le très court
terme quand vous voulez changer une
ville et partant de là puisque vous
parliez des mères quand vous voulez
transformer une ville vous réfléchissez
à la ville que voulait construire à
l'horizon de 10 15 20 30 ans et vos
décisions elles s'inscrivent dans ce
cadre et parce qu'elles s'inscrivent
dans ce cadre vous transformer la ville
petit à petit ce que je dis c'est pas
c'est vrai mais c'est pas du tout propre
au havre tous les maires de droite de
gauche ou d'ailleurs savent ce que je
suis en train de dire et ils vivent ils
ont tous une vision assez claire de ce
que doit être de ce que pourrait être
leur ville à l'horizon de 20 ou 30 ans
eh bien je pense que notre pays doit
faire la même chose notre pays doit
réfléchir à ce qu'il veut être à
l'horizon 2040 à l'horizon 2050 et c'est
en réfléchissant collectivement et en
faisant des choix et en site tenant quel
que soit en s'y tenant qu'on obtient en
effet vous avez ce que je dis là c'est
du gros bon sens franchement ça devrait
être une évidence et j'espère à certains
égards que saleh j'observe que souvent
le débat politique se concentre sur des
instruments techniques alors même que
l'on se pique de faire de la politique
sur des instruments techniques il faut
faire si dans les trois mois dans les
deux mois dans les six mois c'est très
intéressant j'ai sans doute beaucoup
donné dans ce travers donc je le dis
avec humilité mais je pense que ça n'est
pas comme ça qu'on règle durablement les
affaires de notre pays donc voir loin
c'est essayer de définir collectivement
une stratégie faire des choix et essayer
de les tenir dans la durée il n'y a pas
d'organisation collective un état une
ville peut être même une grande
entreprise qui n'obtiennent des
résultats sans savoir où il veut aller à
long terme et sans multiplier les choix
dans le sens de cette direction alors il
faut quand même se préparer
vous le dites est ce que cette formation
politique que vous allez lancer c'est
une manière de vous préparer
intellectuellement et politiquement pour
reprendre vos termes à servir votre pays
à en être à sa tête
mais c'est une formation politique s'est
toujours fait pour participer au débat
public pour contribuer au débat public
pour participer à la vie politique donc
bien entendu moi j'ai dit les choses le
plus clairement possible et je suis très
heureux que vous m'offrez y ait la
possibilité de revenir pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 1 2 je soutiens
le président de la république j'espère
qu'il sera candidat je souhaite qu'il
soit candidat et je le soutiendrai par
cohérence par loyauté et aussi parce que
je pense que c'est ma vision d'intérêt
général ensuite ensuite il faut aider
ensuite il faut aider le président de la
république à mettre en oeuvre les
engagements qu'il prendra à mettre en
oeuvre un certain nombre de choix dont
je considère qu'ils sont utiles au pays
eh ben c'est ce que je vais essayer
faire très loyalement et avec beaucoup
de détermination et d'un filet vous avez
effectivement été très clair sur vos
ambitions présidentielles de 2022 vous
n'irez pas vous avez été moins claire
sur les législatives est ce que ça peut
être un objectif pour vous ces
législatives un moyen de peser dans la
future majorité est ce que vous serez
vous-même candidat
mais que tu ais je suis maire du havre
je pense que il a échappé à personne que
c'était un mandat que j'aimais tant dans
le mans et que je souhaitais exercer
et j'ai une une assez grande une assez
grande capacité à me méfier de ceux qui
pensent aux échéances qui sont
postérieurs à la suivante voyez je
trouve que là encore on n'est pas dans
ce que doit être le débat public il ya
une présidentielle qui vient
et c'est un moment important qu'il faut
prendre au sérieux pour la vie publique
nationale il faut qu'on expose les
options et il faut qu'on fasse des choix
c'est à ça que ça sert une campagne et
les campagnes il faut les prendre au
sérieux alors ne parlons pas de la
campagne qui suivra puis la compagnie
suivra puis la campagne qui sur un
parlant de celle ci exposant les enjeux
présentons les choix faisons ces choix
et pensons à notre pays plutôt que des
stratégies électoralistes je le dis
sincèrement tranquillement pensons à
notre pays merci beaucoup merci edouard
philippe d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin depuis votre visuel où se déroule
donc pendant deux jours ce havre forum
qui est consacré vous l'avais dit à
l'économie bleus merci beaucoup d'avoir
été en direct avec nous et doit finir
[Musique]